en este vídeo quiero introducirte a una
terminología para tipos básicos de
ángulos y bueno la terminología en la
cual te quiero introducir son ángulos
agudos tenemos ángulos agudos y tenemos
ángulos rectos ángulos rectos y ángulos
obtusos entonces creo que ya una vez
analizando cada uno de estos era todo
más sencillo y bueno un ángulo agudo es
un ángulo lo voy a dibujar primero
entonces para que tenga más sentido todo
así que siempre la geometría se ve mejor
cuando lo dibujas bueno entonces bueno
un dibujo dos rayos que salen del mismo
punto y el ángulo que forman este ángulo
este es el ángulo agudo ahora también
podrá dibujar aquí podía dibujar ángulos
bueno dos líneas y los ángulos aquí
estos éste y éste son ángulos agudos
entonces ambos son ángulos agudos
veremos que los ángulos agudos son
ángulos que son bueno de hecho son los
más pequeños son ángulos más pequeños
que un ángulo recto y los ángulos rectos
son cuando dos rayos o dos líneas
son o bueno o van bueno por lo que
quiero decir es cuando cuando dos líneas
se cortan de manera perpendicular es
decir si yo tengo una línea que va así
de manera horizontal y la otra va en
dirección vertical mejor luego con rayos
entonces tengo un rayo que va de
izquierda a derecha luego otro rayo que
va de abajo hacia arriba el ángulo que
forman es un ángulo recto puede
etiquetarlo de esta manera como un
ángulo tradicional pero la comprensión
general para decir que es un ángulo
recto simplemente ponemos una cajita ajá
entonces esta cajita me indica que ese
es un ángulo recto me dice que esta
línea es totalmente horizontal con
respecto a la otra línea y que la otra
línea es totalmente vertical con
respecto a la línea horizontal por eso
por eso es llamado ángulo recto entonces
simplemente van de esta manera
horizontal y vertical se cortan en un
ángulo recto ahí forman un ángulo recto
y ponemos esa cajita entonces la voy a
dibujar con unas líneas si yo tengo una
línea así
y otra línea así un ángulo recto aquí
aquí hace bueno este este ángulo recto
así que todos los otros ángulos sean
rectos ajá bueno entonces quiere decir
que estas líneas y una fuera del piso
supongamos que que este es el piso
entonces la otra línea está
completamente derecha relativa a la otra
línea eso quiere decir que es un ángulo
recto al que forman bueno en sí son
cuatro ángulos rectos y ahora que ya
definimos ángulo recto vamos con ángulo
agudo
estos son ángulos agudos ajá como puedes
ver es un ángulo que mide menos y un
recto este mide 90 grados mientras que
estos miden menos de 90 este ángulo es
menor a 90 grados y para conceptualizar
esto tú puedes ver aquí este ángulo es
menor que 90 entonces si por ejemplo tú
viajas del radio de abajo al radio de
arriba y los solapas tardas menos de 90
grados en llegar a él en cambio acá en
el ángulo recto tú tardas un cuarto de
círculo para llegar a la otra línea para
recorrer 90 grados
agudo solo debes moverte un poquito así
que un ángulo agudo mide menos de un
ángulo recto y bueno tal vez ya te
imaginaste lo que es un ángulo obtuso
ahora bien amboy a dibujar aquí un
ángulo obtuso los ángulos obtusos miden
más que un ángulo recto entonces no
obtuso se mirarán algo así si éste fuera
un ángulo recto
el rayo saldría de aquí ajá estaría
completamente derecho relativo al otro
rayo pero no entonces este ángulo tiene
más anchura por lo tanto se llama un
ángulo obtuso mide más que un ángulo
recto entonces un ángulo agudo aquí
bueno este es un ángulo obtuso un ángulo
obtuso ahora un ángulo agudo es el más
pequeño tipo de ángulo que hay ajá
entonces este ángulo mide menos de 90 es
como el más pequeño el más sensible el
más lindo como duro no bueno no sé si lo
está explicando bien si haga bien la
analogía pero pero si es como el más
pequeño bueno es más sensible mientras
que el obtuso es como el obtuso no sea
el obtuso el grande
el ángulo monstruo entonces bueno una
manera de pensar en esto es que se abre
más su anchura es mayor al ángulo recto
es mayor a 90 grados mayor a 90 grados
entonces tendrías que rotar este este
radio mucho más para llegar al otro rayo
cierto entonces el ángulo recto sólo
rotas un cuarto de círculo y el ángulo
agudo bueno mucho menos que eso si yo
dibujará esto con niñas tenemos que se
forman aquí dos pares de ángulos
entonces bueno cuáles son agudos y
cuáles son obtusos este y éste son
ángulos agudos cierto porque miden menos
de 90 mientras que estos otros dos este
ángulo y éste miden más de 90 son
obtusos estos son obtusos de hecho aquí
es igual a este dibujo aquí tenemos este
ángulo y este otro ángulo son obtusos es
muy sencillo esta idea y bueno por
ejemplo ok si este ángulo aquí aquí
puedes ver que esta línea relativa a la
otra está totalmente derecha cierto como
un edificio en el piso entonces ahí
tenemos un ángulo recto
si los rayos que se forman miden menos
de 90 grados si la apertura es muy
pequeña es un ángulo agudo mientras que
este otro ángulo es un ángulo obtuso así
se le llama porque mide más de 90 grados